normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government here's
a story from Zero Hedge 64 US Bank
branches filed to shut down in a single
week are you affected uh listen it may
not be my bank that shut down I'm not
saying you know maybe uh your bank shut
down but regardless of whether it was
your personal Branch yo you're all
affected Bank branches are shutting down
and so the question is why is it
happening well obviously the economy is
pretty Bonkers right now it doesn't make
sense at all you've got people who can't
afford to eat and you've got casinos
popping up all over the place I swear
the casino thing really makes me think
we're in like the end of days Chicago
just approved recently a$ 1.6 billion
Bal casino on the river in the city and
they just opened the first Chicago
Casino B's temporary location and I'm
like when they start legalizing gambling
across the board and casinos are popping
up and what does a casino do you just
give money away I mean you you could win
money but come on it's you're paying for
entertainment the simplest form of a
casino is you go there you lose money
you have fun you have drinks you leave
they're popping up all over the place
meaning there's a lot of people with
disposable income at the same time there
are way too many people with no income
at all that can't afford to live and
can't afford to get houses they can't
afford to buy
groceries this it can't maintain itself
so they're saying one of the reasons the
banks are closed down is that everyone's
just doing digital right now so they
don't need them and I'm like yeah that's
not that's not it like probably but if
the economy was doing well and the banks
were doing well they would keep their
locations open for marketing purposes
and just to have an available loc
location for people who are just
happening to be in the area I get it is
a fair point why I keep a bank branch
open if everyone's online anyway but if
you had the money you would there's not
a lot going into opening a bank branch I
guess they can fire a lot of of people I
guess in the long run they save a lot of
money I think the real issue is we have
seen what six Banks entire Banks shut
down this year yeah it's been really a
lot of banks it's been scary and now
we're seeing Bank branches shutting down
I'm not going to sit back while the
people in the media are like this is
totally normal and everyone's fine the
stock market will be great and just keep
doing your thing I'm like nah me
personally I don't know I'll buy some
Bitcoin or something maybe get some
property in Argentina yo we were looking
at property in Argentina oh on the
pompas it's beautiful there well no all
I know is you can get there we found
like 500 Acres that was only accessible
by raft and it's like four grand and I'm
like it's that's that seems pretty great
I was in argena good luck getting there
but can you get starlink yes there you
go I was there for a theater conference
in 2003 and it was like this uh this
like compound in the pompus uh it was
really exceptional and Off the Grid and
pretty wacky I recommend
Argentina you know for all those who are
preparing for the apocalypse they Sal
avor sounding pretty good Argentina
especially wow you know I made the joke
I'm like can we elect Javier mle in the
United States somehow is there like some
special role going bring him into need
him right now don't be too quick I mean
they still do have 140% inflation when
he pulls off the C Central uh the
Central Bank down there we'll see what
happens so you're saying wait till it
bottoms out and then buy and then buy I
mean I I don't know look I mean they've
been lying about this economy to the
American public for so long with
mortgage rates up around almost 8%
that's that's absurd like that I mean we
look at 2008 and what happened with 2008
when the adjustable rate mortgages
started just going up ever so slightly
and all of a sudden these people
couldn't afford their $250,000 home
anymore that was an $800 payment and now
it ballooned to $1,700 and they're like
well that's the same thing that's
happening right now if right exactly
everyone that bought everyone that
bought a home in 2020 is like probably
in the wor I would not want to be in
their situation right now because it's
it's cheaper to rent right now than it
is to buy at home but yeah everyone that
bought in 2020 like they're watching
that that interest rate go up and just
hoping if they have like a variable
interest rates though yeah yeah I don't
know how many people are doing that
these days they still do the variable
interest rates I mean that's appealing
right now but I I I don't know what the
adjustable rates are at right now I just
looked at the fixed but cuz cuz you're
cuz you you don't want to go in at 8% so
you're like I'll take 6% variable yeah
and then it goes to 15 and you're like
you're that's what happens yeah I
wouldn't do that yeah so many people
would they don't know they don't
understand how it works and they just do
it I would just take like the lowest I
could get buy down for points
well and the Market's great too like my
house right now is worth significantly
more than it was when we bought it in
like 2015 significantly more like to the
point where I'm telling my wife like we
need to sell the home and buy an RV and
just drive around the country for a year
wait till all this sorts itself out and
then when it comes back down we can buy
a home and own it outright and not have
a mortgage payment or anything like that
but you can't buy anything in the
meantime you can't Reby at 8% I
mean I was talking to my mom about this
and she was buying uh you know she's
fine now but she was buying real estate
in like the 80s and '90s and stuff and
she was telling me that her her first
home that she bought it was like you
know 12% and they thought that was
pretty good at the time and that was in
the 80s you know so
uh yeah it has changed rather
significantly just our sense of what a
normal interest rate is I'm locked in at
2.75 and I'm staying there nice congrats
I not I I if if the economy gets worse
then Trump's
unbeatable yeah Trump Carlson 2024 with
a crumbling economy Banks shutting down
everywhere crime through the roof he's
going to come back out he's going to
give his first rally and he's going to
go for those listening I'm just
shrugging or or a very very very deadly
virus somehow makes its way over here
with a 99.99%
survival rate and we have to shut down
Everything
99 that's deadly 9 deadly survival rate
I don't you you were right I was trying
to make a joke I don't think that will
work again no it won't that's why
they're trying to get him off the ballot
right so the the real play is going to
have to be some kind of Trumps not
eligible one one of my thoughts is that
they the the the neocon neol
establishment when I say they uh is
resigned to the fact they're gonna lose
and so the play is set Trump up for
massive failure look at Afghanistan
Biden chose to to to destroy Afghanistan
to to I mean this was this was a
deliberate action by the United
States if Trump was in office the
Afghanistan withdrawal would have been
fine would it have been great no that's
ridiculous there's probably bad things
that going happen but abandoning bam Air
Force Base in the middle of the night I
think it's possible that the Biden
Administration said let's make
Afghanistan the biggest disaster F in in
in in you know of Our Generation so that
way we can be like oh no look go when
you withdraw look at all the bad things
we can withdraw now oh it'll be
Afghanistan all over again then Syria
then Iran whatever else we're going to
invade the playmate now may be let Trump
fine he's going to win we'll just make
sure that there's landmines every step
he takes and then we'll say you see what
happens when you elect someone like
Donald
Trump maybe I mean I think Trump has
popular support it it will be anybody
who takes office has to unravel Biden's
mess and that will always be an issue um
but I think generally the sentiment is
that no one could be worse than Biden
and even if they were to switch him out
for Gavin Nome it's expensive to live in
California right like I don't want his
economic policies either and so there's
no one on Democratic bench that they
could suddenly pull up before next year
who's like a who will win the economic
argument I think Americans are
completely voting based on how what how
much they're paying in gases and how
much they're paying in groceries and
ultimately it has to be a republican the
Republican states are fairing better not
great but a lot of them are better off
and Trump has the popular confidence
vote I mean people believe Trump can
make a difference what what it will
actually look like that obviously makes
us nervous but it can't be a Democrat
Democrat states and cities are failing
for
this yeah that's true wh who could possi
oh she is so terrible oh she's terrible
but Democrats don't have anybody even
even Nome can't Spin The N he can't
pitch the story there's no Newsome story
Trump's got a character AR Trump's got a
story Trump's got Pol in Colorado who I
know my polus I know but nobody knows
who that is oh yeah I mean he had his
moment with the tread on me kid right
right there is there is no Democrat that
has xfactor not a single
one I know my my co-host on why we vote
is literally cringing right now because
I said Paul she's from Colorado and
cannot
stand can't win his own State there's no
way it could be him I think you're right
there's there's no Democrat that that
has it and part of it is because none of
them are good at the economy and that's
what's going to matter this this round I
mean all right fine I'll say it Michelle
Obama nope no you don't think so you
don't think they they would roll her out
maybe maybe but I don't think she has
the story I don't think she can spin the
story what are they going to say Biden
is the Obama Administration the reason
they wanted Biden was because they
wanted to be like Obama I remember Obama
and now it's bad Michelle Obama's going
to come out and be like we're going to
try Obama again yeah and people are
going to be like I don't know 3.0 maybe
maybe I mean that NBC new news poll if
you like the polls maybe you don't they
said any any Democratic candidate versus
Trump wins and so maybe maybe not r m he
actually has Biden up in the polls
against Trump surprisingly the one the
one poll in the in the Real Clear
Politics aggregate M well you still
don't we're still not even factoring in
that that Biden is also on top of all
the atrociousness with the economy and
you know foreign policy and everything
else he's still running against RFK Jr
and Cornell West and we're going to get
a fourth person in here somebody from
that independent party ticket is going
to you know I know Mitt Romney said he
doesn't want it you know somebody else
is going to get in there whether it's
Joe Manion Joe Mansion well it's going
to be I think it's going to be a split
ticket and if they put the Republican on
top that could
have some of the you know establishment
Republicans that are still out there
will rally behind that that could
actually hurt Trump a little bit but uh
I mean the the the RFK junr thing I
think is going to absolutely Crush uh uh
Biden no shot thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net